Labour's deputy leader Tom Watson has
today called for the party to back a
second brexit referendum or risk losing
the next general election and pressure
on the leadership could grow further if
the EU election results are as bad as
some in a party fear well joining us now
is the Shadow Chancellor John McDonnell
thank you very much for being with us
this morning and I take it you've read
and Tom Watson's piece today he's
calling for labour to move unequivocally
to bat a second referendum is it time to
do so I know I understand where Tom's
coming from and I think he's expression
the sort of frustration he feels and
many of our members feel but I'm and I
understand that completely we've had
we've had to take a hard road over the
last period because we yes we are strong
remain party a majority of our members
I'll remain a lot of our supporters as
well but we couldn't ignore the fact
that you know 52% of the population
voter of those electorate voted leave we
can't turn our back on those people and
that's why we've trade a really
difficult role Road of trying to bring
people together trying to get a
negotiated settlement that protects the
economy and jobs with the Conservative
government that's failed and clearly now
we have to have another conversation and
I think the next step for us now is
bringing well bringing the other
opposition parties together for a
discussion about where we go from here
and yes talking to a number of those
Conservative MPs as well because as
you've seen in the interviews you that
you've been doing there's a real threat
now of an extremist brexit ear becoming
the leader of the Conservative Party and
taking us over the edge of the cliff
edge of a no deal no matter what damage
there is to jobs and the economy so I
think yes we have to have that
conversation not just within the
parliamentary Labour Party amongst our
members and supporters but also with the
other opposition parties as well as I
say with conservative MPs too because
we've got to move to block or no deal
and move forward now so yes we know we
now need to have that discussion about
how we can prevent this damage to our
economy don't you need to do more than
just have more talks more discussion so
you actually need to come to
because actually say it's one thing
taking a kind of relaxed long-term
approach when you know pretty much that
Therese may could just ask for another
extension but now the leading contenders
to talk about leaving with no deal at
the end of October something you want to
prevent yeah
isn't it time for labour to now decide
do you want to have another referendum
no we've said already we've said for to
block or No Deal we'll work with anyone
we'll work across now don't we but we
are that's what we will do we will bring
people together now we want to see the
other opposition parties we want to make
sure we have that conversation within
our own party and with some of those
conservative MPs have said like us they
will not vote for a No Deal brexit and
yes we've said that if necessary yes but
let's have a general election about this
but if necessary yes let's go back to
the people again we've said that and
we've voted for that in the House of
Commons but we're now in a critical
situation we could be in a situation
where as I say we're an extremist brexit
it takes over the leadership of the Tory
party no matter what the damage there is
to the jobs in the economy and try and
force that through so I think the world
changed on Friday when Theresa May stood
down we're facing a very very precarious
and dangerous situation for the future
of our country
and yes I think the responsibilities on
all of those opposition parties to come
together with us and some conservative
MPs to block an Odeon if that means
going back to the people yes let's go
back to the people so if the world
changed has your own personal view
shifted on whether or not a referendum
is the right thing to do well we've
always worked through what our
conference policy was which was trying
well try and secure a deal if we can
block a No Deal certainly block a bad
deal try and secure a deal we possibly
can and then if we can't do that if we
can't get agreement on a cross-party and
get through the House of Commons then
seek a general election or failing that
yes then go on to back to the public and
I think we've worked through those
stages now we need to bring I think we
need to take there's a vacuum of
leadership in this country now since
Theresa May stood down now's the time we
were I think this the
a party's role now to demonstrate that
leadership bring the other opposition
leaders together talk through and get
agreement on a way forward and if that
does include going back to the people
yes let's now have that discussion
consult our party members consult the
farmers relate by consult the other
opposition parties and let's go forward
we've got to block a No Deal we cannot
allow the brexit ear extremists like
Boris Johnson or any other candidates in
this little Grand National race that has
been set off the Tory party to push us
over the edge of a No Deal it will
impact upon people's livelihoods we're
going to be getting the European
election results later on this evening
the Lib Dems expected to do well near
the green party expects to do well in
his piece today Tom Watson said our
performance is a direct result of our
mealy-mouthed backing for a public vote
on brexit do you think are you worried
that in an increasingly polarized debate
labour is just falling through the
middle here well I think we must
probably we'll get a good kicking in the
election results tonight we'll see we'll
see we're braced for that but you know
we had to do the responsible thing I
know it was hard and it was difficult
was a hard road to follow but we someone
had to be there and say can we bring the
country back together again and it would
have been easy to go to one side you
know to the remain slight and ignored
all those people who voted leave that's
not the nature of our party we're the
party that is trying to bring people
back together again that's been
difficult electorally for us in these
elections of course it has but now we've
got to move on the reality is as I said
on Friday when Theresa May stood down
there was a dramatic change in the
nature of our politics and we're now
faced with well Tory party candidates
who literally to just get the job a Tory
party leader are appealing to their
members as you seen in the polls a
majority of whom are pressing for No
Deal no matter what the consequences for
people's jobs their livelihoods and the
future of our economy and our country we
can't allow that to happen we've got to
move forward now bring people together
and block a No Deal and if that means
going back to
people so be it and then just finally
everyone of course was watching when
Theresa May stood on the steps of
Downing Street and announced her
resignation very emotional speech did
you feel sorry for her yeah you know I
said the other day in an interview you
you would have had to have a heart of
stone not to feel for her I know others
have commented and said you know I also
feel for all the victims of her policies
and I do too but yes of course I did and
look I I wish her well for the future
and and you know she's done their best
but it hasn't been good enough we've got
to move on now and part of that moving
on isn't just about brexit its
addressing all that human suffering
that's been inflicted but yes Theresa
Mays administration and the nine years
of austerity that she's supported you
know we had the UN reporter reporting
over this last month about our children
in hunger v biggest economy in the world
and our children some of them are living
in hunger homelessness on a scale 5000
people sleeping on our streets tonight
crime up our social services now
stretched so far they can't provide the
social care our elderly need so yes I
had an of course add an element of
personal concern and sympathy for in
that emotional period but I also have to
look beyond that of the record of nine
years of austerity in the the brutal the
brutal way in which our people have been
treated by the administration that she's
either led or been a supporter of